I think goty on on the screen who else
is on
screen me oh yeah K yeah can't see from
here
small far away as we
can just in case we were in the wrong
room
so any apologies for
absence anybody I think we're all
here any Declarations of Interest
no thank you item three minutes of the
last
meeting thank
you we item four equality plan and
objective
um well I'd like to say thanks to C for
do this equality P I think it's one of
the best ones I've seen quite a
while um don't you want me to read out
the briefing notes or not but I think it
covers everything it it covers the uh
inclusivity and all all that sort of
stuff so I'm really pleased with it
um put you know putting this one forward
so um we're required as a council uh
under the public sector equality uh due
to psed to set equality objective every
four years the equality objectives have
been Incorporated in the council's new
equality pump which is appended and uh
which sets out our legal
responsibilities the council's approach
to qualitative profile of the district
and Workforce the four equality
objectives and actions to achieve
those the equality objectives are
improving customer and Resident insight
for service planning and delivery
purposes providing leadership and
organizational commitment to
actively promote equalities inclusion
and
accessibility ensuring a diverse and
engaged Workforce continuing to embed
British sign language chart
pledges the equality plan and objectives
have been consulted on a widely with and
widely comments and suggestions taken on
board um also such the report final
review of the equality plan
29th three that's appendix two which
gives examples of how the council has
met its equality duties
and specific equality objectives much of
which improves service access and choice
that supports customers residents like
then just reiterate how how pleased I am
with it as a as a
policy thank you C do you want to
anything uh only TW it's been U it's
been great that the portfolio holder has
really got an interest in this area so
it's been nice to engage with Council
Barry on this uh on this document so so
I'm looking forward to taking this piece
of work forward and it's good timing
with the new council plan and also hits
a lot of the uh objectives in that
plan thank
you and it is I like it it's uh it's a
good document really really that's where
we at with all the uh quality and
diversity stuff so well done to
everybody oh you want to move the
recommendation yeah so any more
questions for
happy yeah so i' like to move the
recommendations to approve and adopt the
equality plan and objectives for 2023 to
2027 and to note the achievements and
the progress made under the last two
years um of the previous plan of 2019
2023 thank you I'll take
that yeah are we all in favor that thank
you lovely thank that's
good uh I'll move on to item five the
safeguarding policy and procedures
protecting children and adults at risk
uh and that's in that's in my name uh
but D here who' done the the
paperwork again a really good uh
document I think uh it does seem a bit
familiar but we've just done all this at
at school Governor last week it is a
massive thing at the moment
safeguarding uh quite rightly and I
think what it it stresses up right
throughout all the documentation and and
uh the actual thing is that safeguarding
everybody's responsibility I think that
we've all got a part to play in this uh
and it's it really is uh well up there
on the agenda is it for trying to keep
people
safe uh and D you want to sort to do
yeah I'll give a bit background
information of how this come about what
actually is if that's okay yeah so we
attend a group The darbishire District
Safeguard in lead subgroup long title
well there you go um Leah can originally
set that up and what it is um all the um
la come together throughout darbishire
there's a representative from each one
and we talk about everything to do with
safeguarding also attended is um adult
social care from DCC and children's um
services so basically we talk about Pol
IES procedures we talk about any um
reviews um and this has actually come
from there so it was decided I attend
that now sorry um in um Lee's absence
there in on his
behalf um so it was decided at that
group that we ought to have a darish
wide policy because everybody is working
to dcc's um policies and procedures so
and we've all got different policies but
it says exactly the same thing in it so
for consistency but some of them are all
over Place some have two policies like
we did or have got currently and some
have got one so I was on the uh working
group to do that um along with two other
local authorities and we've come up with
an idea to do one policy uh for both
children and adults and do a um the
crooks of the policy and then put
information sheets instead it being in
the main body of the policy and so they
can be changed because Safeguard it's
changing rapidly
consistantly so they can be changed
without it coming back to cabinet and we
can change the link officers so we
drafted one policy for all the hopefully
or the um local authorities to adopt it
shows partnership working with DCC
partnership working consistently across
arer and it's all working together um
for referrals our policies and
procedures what we've actually got in
place now won't have to change at all
because each local Authority can adapt
and have I have done that in this one
have adapted it to work to our policy
and procedure which is the same as
everybody else's but we call it
different things we've got link offices
somebody else might have um safeguarding
Champions um so I've amended this I've
adapted it to Northeast arish District
Council got all the link offices in
place all the referrals will be EXA the
same the training is the same everything
is the same the only difference is we've
got two policies currently we've going
to put it into one policy it's going to
be a darbishire wide one that
everybody's going to use for partnership
and consistency across darbishire now
this has been to the S boards as well
and that sorry the safeguarding adult
boards and the children's boards and
they're very excited about this policy
to be quite honest and think it's a it's
a really good thing that we are actually
doing um so yeah so it's been there it's
been approved by them been approved by
everybody at DCC that needs to approve
it um so I'm just looking for your
approval to adopt it this one um this
one would replace the two that we've
already got in
situm and for me that's good because I I
originally did policies of two policies
I've been doing them for years I've been
reviewing them for years this one will
go back to uh car District Safeguard in
the sub group for review so we'll all be
reviewing it at the same time any new
legislation that comes through and it
could be sort of a best practice that
we're all taking on board at the same
time any new legislation that comes out
I can just amend it stick it in in the
main bdes anything that comes up from
the information sheets on all the append
I can remove them put fresh ones in and
we've actually a fresh one come out
yesterday modern slavery so I've I I
actually wrote quite a few of these
information sheets but I will be
amending that one before it gets
published um because some new procedures
have come out from that just yesterday
so it is ever changing but the main
Crooks of the policy when that gets
changed that will come here again after
a review but I will be changing the
information sheets as and when they
needed and that complies with dcc's
procedures and legislation that comes
then um if we do need to change link
officers I can I want to be able to
change them as well because obviously
people leave we get new ones in we have
to have a certain amount um but anything
else that comes through back to Cabinet
after
review that's L though thank you that's
the basically is lot of work on I don't
I know you were involved like you said
at the beginning you
been yeah yeah long while but I would
like I mean d too moded
um this past six years um that
safeguarding
systems changed from a disconnected
system I think across the county into
one that's very connected very efficient
but it's Northeast arishu was led the
way and all of that they've been at the
floor front and I'd personally like to
put my thanks on record for D because D
I'm the safeg guardian lead but D does
all the leg work these days she goes to
all the meetings she produces all the
policies and she do and she Champions
Northeast arish should but the issue of
safeguarding across the county so not
sure that came across so why I want to
get it thank you say that about
myself thank you yeah no I think I like
all that i' read that from not just from
Le but from others the man work that
that's run into this and that we at
Northeast have been leading on it and
like I said at the beginning uh it
really is toput tree Now safeguarding
everywhere you go
there safeguarding leads every school's
got to have one governing bodies have
got to have one every Authority's got to
have a a safeguarding thing so uh and it
hopefully it doesn't affect it
does end up safeguarding people yeah it
is working it is working we do keep
stats on it and we are getting a lot of
referrals so um I think more people are
becoming more aware of it than they've
ever been so I have some fig
first two quarters it's been 48 I think
I think the other message is even if you
don't think it's all it's better to
report it than the wish you had in
it that's that's the message because
sometimes you think that don't feel
right but well not make a for but you
you I mean I don't don't or meeting
seeing folks in go up or some and you
think not treating that kid very well
everyone of them reviews it's always
only always only would have shared
something that and that it's about
coordinating all that because in past
things have been
missed I
think I mean and if it amounts to no it
don't matter does it
there's a saying if it feels wrong it
generally is so with your thought on
some things yeah yeah okay thank you
I'll I'll move the recommendations then
that uh to seek cabinet approval and
adopt the final draft of the darish
award policy safeguarding policy and
procedures protecting children adults at
risk thank you I'll move that thank
you we all in favor adop thanks so it's
councelor car second the motion I second
it see you thank you
bye agent items any agent item uh I've
got
none and uh then it's it will lead to
item s exclud the public that
that
neighborhood
very
you end being managing
direct no I'll read it there the public
be excluded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following items of
business to avoid the disclosure to them
of exempt information as defined in part
one of the schedule 12a to the local
government
1972 as amended by the local
government access to information
variation order
2006 category of exempt information is
stated the
item